how do I overcome my insecurities about
matter given what your mission is I
think it's great to even share that like
I think you should share that you're
feeling insecure about it because you
become a hero like that is that is
heroic if you think it's great yeah and
it's gonna win for sure and you put it
out there's nothing heroic in that right
it's in the I'm I'm afraid and I'm doing
it anyway then that gives permission to
other people to do the same thing every
time you tell the story the judgment
burns a little less so when you're
feeling nervous it's great it means
you're doing something heroic yeah and
you need to share that like I'm a rap
singer songwriter yeah with influences
of self motivation lyrics overt rap
instrumentals that kind of fit in the
form that the youth need because they
they all listen to trap music but rap
music has terrible lyrics so I'm trying
to fill that form but with shots fired
and so I think the starting point there
is clothes you just need to you need to
make it a little more powerful to think
about like what is the problem that you
solve with your music what is it yeah
yeah you don't have the perfect answer
no yeah we'll work through it
freestyling sure well the problem I
think is that you know kids are easily
influenced at a very young age and all
of these you know huge rap artists are
influencing them in the wrong direction
towards drugs the only kid violence not
gay
I mean adults too okay I'm not talking
kids like young teenagers to young
adults I think that's my target audience
okay and I think that they need to have
inspirational lyrics in a form that they
like like to listen to so I know that
all these instrumentals are very similar
and I can produce them and I have
friends that produce them so I want to
provide the same melody but with a more
inspirational lyrics on top of that how
much are you into the trap and and you
know the rapping part versus the
inspiring kids or youth it's it's like
50/50 for me because I obviously I
listen to
a lot of that music rightly I'm also
really really into watching your videos
and right I'm you know soft improvement
and you know reading books Fitness
meditation trying to contrast both of
those and bring it into my music like if
trap goes away yeah or when it fades and
something else comes up then what then
I'm gonna keep on doing my music in
whatever form I feel comes from the
heart
so you'll adjust your music style I
would yes but still with the same yessum
idea yeah for sure why do you care so
much about the youth like I mean there's
lots of causes to care about you care
about the environment you can care about
Toronto you can care about in-home
somewhere right like why do you care so
much about this right well I do care
about the environment and I think that
our youth I think our youth are gonna be
a huge proponent and changing the
environment so I think that you know if
they're influenced to you know getting a
new Gucci bag instead of you know
investing in the future like why yeah
yes okay you care about the environment
too great but like there's a million
charities out there yes
there's a million causes out there yeah
why youth so much over everything else
hmm why you thought fallen tiered animal
shelters yeah I make music said that
dogs can listen to when they're at home
and their parents you know their owners
go out or whatever right yeah like
there's a there's a lot of different
causes which are all great and all Noble
and like if somebody asks you hey Alex
any help come help us out you know you
probably say yes but mm-hmm
like why you're making this like your
thing yeah which is great yeah so I
think your purpose comes from your pain
like the reason why I do what I do
helping entrepreneurs is because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur
that you know I felt so worthless as a
human when I first started my business
that I want to try to make the path a
little bit easier right for other people
mm-hmm just jump on that I feel like
I've always struggled with being
influenced by other people okay and
influenced by the music that I listen to
okay and so I wanted to provide like a
resource of music for people that they
can listen to and not feel like they're
going to be led in the wrong door
okay did you do something stupid I mean
I had a yeah I had a stupid youth you
know I like everyone partying too much
and stuff like that but because of the
music not because of the music and
because of the people in my life - I'm a
very it was a very easily influenced
person okay and let me down the wrong
path and I wanted to get back to that
and provide music for these kids our
youth and young adults that is
influential that's the story yeah
however much you're willing to you not
to say it now but like however what
you're willing to admit mm-hmm and it
may involve other people that you need
to change like names and genders and
like roles and whatever right but but
that is the story mmm how you were
influenced and that took you down the
wrong path and you found like what was
the turning point that made you it was a
was music seriously I was in university
two years in I was in a really dark
place in my life and I I started
creating music every day and that was
what drugged me out of that dark place
you creating your own music creating my
own music yep creating the beats
creating my own vocals writing and we'll
look to that what led to that it was a
random thing or you know it was just it
was passion I guess so I started going
to more music festivals and like
appreciating music at a deeper core
level and it just started to take my
soul away like nothing else had it took
my breath away and so I needed to do it
and I needed to do it every day and it
just grew into this passion and I wanted
it to be something inspiring so I
started adding that to my music what was
there an artist that you listened to I
want to see that made you feel oh like
it usually can be positive - and not
just negative um well a lot of the EDM
genre is like that you know at the very
end of a festival there would be just
huge inspiring like you can be more like
okay that's cut that kind of stuff and
then there's a smaller rap artists like
seven like you
Gary Vee is given on my huge grace
because all of his lyrics are very very
inspirational okay like they're each
song like grateful selfish they're all
very like motivational and he is a big
inspiration for me as well right and
pushing me to do this Gary you're the
artist are both well both Gary's amazing
yeah so that's that's the story because
instead of it just being here's the
thing if you're just talking from a
perspective of hey
I think youth are gonna change the world
and they're gonna change environment and
it's very very great yeah I'm like one
who are you to be the guy right and so
said but but like no I'm I'm I was one
of them right like I was influenced
negatively and and this is where it led
me and and you know here's what I did
you know I hate in my life or robbed a
jewelry store or like whatever you know
about doing yeah
and and then I found the path and I want
to make it easier for the next
generation and I recognize that music is
the way out because it was the way out
for me because I went the EDM concerts
and I realized hey at the end it's a
type and it's inspiring yeah right and
so now I'm trying to do that but not
through the end but through trap
yeah right so telling that story now
like it connects way more that's the
brain okay right some [ __ ] right
yeah that's your brain yeah you're you
struggled so much you were influenced
negatively and now you want to be a
force for good because you recognize the
power that music has to influence people
to do good or bad things right thank you
I don't know I it seems so new to me to
think that way I guess but like how
willing are you to go into the pain and
explain the negative stuff that because
without that the story doesn't mean
anything I think I'm really I'm ready
dude okay I obviously is a little bit of
fear there yeah you know sharing you
know those deepest since rarities is
scary but I think I'm ready to face that
fear okay yes he made it okay well then
what happened what happened yeah it was
honestly a lot of drugs against I went
through doing you know going out too
much partying doing drugs
meeting them on people I've had some
really terrible relationships with with
women and I you know just wasn't a good
person to my family I learned a lot and
these all these things kind of led to
what was the moment that you felt the
most worthless as a human I think it was
heading into my second year of
university okay and
just basically my girlfriend and I had
just broken up and we I thought this
girl was gonna be my forever girl right
I was basically alone in Waterloo you
know I miss Toronto didn't have my
family there I was kind of by myself and
at that point and I didn't have a laptop
to make music so I had no way of making
music I had basically nothing at that
point and that's when I realized I
needed to start making some changes and
and turn my life around because I was
you know and then the only way I was
feeling good was through doing drugs and
going and going on partying and you know
not not being myself so and at that
point is when I started changing and you
know doing music every day and I saved
up and bought a laptop and you know it
all took off from there
so you you you're you and your
girlfriend split you're sitting in your
in your dorm room in Waterloo yet no
laptop to make music yeah and and what
like take me back there where you lie in
your bed it seemed like my life sucks
yeah no really I was I was in that place
and it just didn't I just didn't feel
whole you know like I I was I was very
very empty and honestly I
I just needed to make change I didn't
know I didn't have any direction other
than I was like that night that you just
had to need to make change it was more
of a gradual process it wasn't like a
specific day I I always knew the music
was gonna be right for me and I knew
that I needed to head towards that but
it wasn't like a specific day where I
was like yes this is the I I've always
just kind of known but I needed to start
I slowly started shifting towards that
right yeah so so I mean that's the story
you could you could bring that into your
lyrics yeah as well that like I said I
struggled I you know I I did drugs I for
sure I had bad relations but I
mistreated my parents like you can have
a song as you really shape with your
parents okay now oh yeah for sure way
better right so like there could be a
song around parenting yeah like your
parents took you around the world when
you're 14 and then you know you did
drugs and she didn't like crap and you
fixed it Yeah right so like great
stories have the
the journey that the negative right and
then you're sorting them back up and SIF
it so if you're only staying high and
positive all the time it's great but if
you're also telling like hey I've been
through this it's it was war it was hell
son and I got through it
now you're more relatable she's not just
perfect perfect guy who has it all
figured out and of course not yeah right
yeah but so showing that then makes me
connect it to you okay the vulnerability
is the connection point right embracing
the negative in a way so you can and how
you how you either got through it or
still dealing with it right like you
know the dreaming song you're still
dreaming yeah right seriously every day
you know you haven't you don't have it
all figured out mmm and that's okay
mmm right like I'm mom might come up I'm
trying to figure out how to make things
work I'm hustling I'm grinding I'm
trying to get it going I don't have all
the answers I'm gonna make mistakes mmm
not that I have it all figured out and
I'm not willing to admit any weakness
because then nobody's gonna connect to
when you're putting out sure yeah
so now figuring out how to tell that
story through the music through the
brain into the design through your
Instagram through your website right
trying to get people to connect with me
at a more core level like my story yeah
and that idea of like I was negatively
influenced yeah and it destroyed my life
almost yeah and now I want to be a
positive influence for the people mm-hmm
right that that keyword or influence hmm
yeah it's super important and that was
one of my other questions was you know
sometimes I need to get the kick out of
bed in the morning yeah and you find
that through getting that inspiration
and sharing your your beliefs with
people as oh is that what this yeah I
think I think creating a schedule is
important sure I think waking up at a
certain time every day is important
there may be off days like if you have a
really late night because you didn't a
gig so you sleep in the next day okay
but but general I think if I didn't have
a schedule like my alarm goes off at 7
o'clock she hug my wife for the first
five minutes and then get up and start
my day mm-hmm and I know that I need to
be here you know before you thirty I
need to get everything else done before
then anytime I say
to make a video so you know I set that
up so that it works but before I had
here it was a commitment I would still
get up at the same time and do that
other part of my morning routine right I
think when you don't have a consistent
start time it's easy to be lazy for sure
okay
and add that's my schedule in my yawns
I'm very inconsistent so I think if you
said like 9 o'clock and wake up every
day yeah or 8 o'clock or like whatever
yeah you want don't you don't have to go
crazy and say ok like 4:30 I have
everyday you know yeah because then you
don't every time you set a goal it's
super important that you do it mmm
because you're building self-respect
right if you say you're gonna wake up at
4:00 third and you don't do it you're
gonna lose respect for yourself right
and you start to build that identity of
like I can't stick to a schedule yeah
it's really negative habit right and
then and then you just forget about
schedule and say well that's not me it's
like no you just you know start right so
like if it's 9 o'clock then gonna wake
up everyday 9 o'clock mm-hmm and then
that clock goes off and you get up yeah
and then do your thing yeah whatever it
is and then the more you stick to that
the more you build respect for yourself
that you set a goal and you do it most
people like hit the snooze button yeah
first thing dangerous yeah do you have
an alarm we just wake up I do have an
alarm okay yeah do you hit the snooze
button I sometimes do yeah I'm bad I'm
bad for that I'm not very like once I
get going I'm gonna person but in the
morning I really struggle so that's one
of my so that's that it makes it hard
because like you set a goal last night
that you gonna wake up at 9 o'clock yeah
today and the very first thing you do is
say yeah I'm not gonna hit my goal right
right off the bat you're not it's not
even like people say get out of bed and
make the bed again you've already I've
already lost yeah like if you start your
day saying I'm not gonna hit my goals
today then it's hard to get close today
yeah right so um if you need extra sleep
then you set it for 9:30 and then I 30
comes and you get up mm-hmm right it's
like disable the snooze disable the
don't let it happen right like because
it because that's that's
teaching you that you you are losing
respect for yourself right I'm gonna
follow through so when you set a goal
you have to go off and do it so having a
routine where you start at certain time
I think it's important right whatever
that makes sense for you and then
creating it so that it's a and automatic
it's like you wake up whatever you do
you brush your teeth yeah you make your
bed meditate and meditate and then like
you go into yeah and then that leads to
the next
so you anchor your habits so that when I
brush my teeth I'm also doing this
mm-hmm right and then that kicks the
rest of your day forward right off
create lyrics like if writing song
lyrics gets you fired up the process
then start your day with that and then
go to the meditation and the workout
right like spend ten minutes fifteen
minutes writing mm-hm
what's my what's my like how do I want
to be a positive influence today right
how do I want to be a positive influence
today through my words and then then
write and maybe become something or
maybe it's yeah that was it it was a
one-time thing that just sits on the
paper and yeah right or I got out of bed
and I you know shake off my head and
start freestyle rapping yeah yeah
exactly and get it on the camera yeah
yeah
Wow if you can record it even better
like if you write it down on paper and
then you take a picture yeah and post
that every day to Instagram yeah your
morning thoughts or if you wake up and
shake your head and then yeah start
rapping yeah every morning that's great
the danger is just don't make it perfect
and then instead of it being a ten
minute thing it's a two hour thing right
yeah just get it out yeah get it out get
it out get it out so when I'm doing mine
I don't know if you've seen my Instagram
what I do in the morning but right now
I'll write four on four different sticky
notes a message and I'll play a song
okay in the background and then I'll
like as the song is playing I'll flip
the stickies you can see what it's
what's written and then when I come down
to the parking garage I'll make a video
usually mm-hmm
about the same message oh cool so but
that's recording time like 30 seconds
right well then the planning process I
have to think of what I want to say I
have to figure out how to put that into
four sticky notes and I'm right on the
sticky note and then find the song and
play it but all in it takes like I don't
know seven minutes
mm-hmm you know and some messages are
better than others ya know some are
super inspired and some are somewhat
inspired but it always fulfills the same
thing as like I enjoy waking up and
trying to serve right and create a
message that's gonna influence people so
figuring that out like if that gets you
excited then then do it yeah sometimes I
struggle with you know I can sit there
and do my art for an hour but then to
keep on foot or hour to and keep on
pushing that creativity and doing it
when I don't feel like it do you have
any recommendations on how to like maybe
push through so I have a daily schedule
yeah where I do different things on
different days so today's Tuesday after
after this I'm gonna be going back and
filming 20 videos from YouTube channel
right I didn't strategize in YouTube for
the rest of the day to build my channel
mm-hmm and every day I do different
things and that schedule helps keep me
focused and the projects that I need to
do and then when I for me I can't just
wait for creativity to ya come up which
is why I said before like when you when
you feel inspired record mm-hmm I don't
know how to say I don't know how to get
myself in the zone every day all day
long yeah maybe maybe there's someone
who knows how to do that but what I do
find is when I get in the zone I try to
stay there as much as possible right so
I'll push other stuff like if if I on
the way home
think of something I will immediately go
off and start to do it mm-hmm when we're
talking about your song dreaming and
like I want to figure out a way how do I
fit this into my content and you're like
yeah you could follow it away somewhere
like no man I don't either like I hate
that I hate filing self-aware it's like
momentum right right and I think it's
super inspired by like that maybe my
entire day was just working on the
dreaming song and figuring out how to
and I'll push my other stuff right
that's on my schedule cuz I'm in the
zone cuz whatever I create when I'm in
that moment is gonna be amazing
mm-hmm right that's like that's the best
of me right but when it's not when I'm
not in the zone on something I have my
schedule to fall back on it's actually
really important for me like I hit
something because I've always struggled
with scheduling and I think I really
need to cement that so one people are
one or the other usually yeah right so
there's some people who love the
schedule everything and like they live
by their schedule but then they never
creative mm-hmm they never find their
zone because they get an idea but then
oh but I got to do this and then I'll
never come back to it mm-hmm
so that's the opposite all right you're
the other way like you get it like man I
don't fire but it's just not consistent
enough so so what it like what do you
have to get done in a week what is your
schedule look like what does it ideal
schedule look like for you to accomplish
your goals ideal schedule is I mean
before this conversation it would be
just to work on my my music every day
like I'm working on an EP right now and
I'm just trying to finalize all the
mixes so put as much out as many hours
as I possibly can into the mixes of that
and then start working on getting the
cover it's done for the album and so
you're doing this full-time right now
not full-time but like when I'm out of
well basically I just finished school
and right now I'm doing I did like it
reads for a while and now I'm going into
more of an audio production job doing
editor and editing for a AI company
they're doing text-to-speech stuff so
I'm just editing so I'm Homer does
semester home so I'm working when you've
set hours so that I set hours yeah when
do you work
oh like a lot of specific hours I guess
I work when I basically throughout the
afternoon okay but I'm a specific
schedule okay so I think but it's a
consistent like number of hours yeah
it's like three to four hours a day for
the everyday yeah okay yeah and so I do
that and obviously I've put try to put
in another three hours or two hours into
music okay so what do you prefer would
you rather there's no right answer it's
like yes or what stands for cosmo yeah
would you rather get the corporate stuff
done first and off your plate and then
focus on your music or would you rather
flip it it's like man now I want to
start with my music and then I'll deal
with the corporate stuff at the end I
think the corporate stuff first okay for
me because I want to get it off my plate
and then have the rest of the day to do
what I want okay
and one of my son Roy teachers always
talked about that as being important
right so like if you could get your
corporate stuff done by noon every day
yeah yeah and then have the rest of the
day to do write your own stuff that'd be
really good actually
so how do you schedule so that by noon
and I'm done all of my corporate work
that probably means I have to wake up
but like 8:00 and then start working you
know 9:00 and we're from 9:00 to 12:00
and then right and then twelve onwards
so if you work up if you wake up at 8:00
and then do your routine yeah freestyle
meditate yeah push-ups
whatever you're doing yeah and then nine
you treat it like look like a normal job
you show up at 9:00 yeah 9:00 to 5:00
you a 9:00 to 12:00 yeah we're gonna get
it but also having that timeline like I
got to get it done by 12:00 mmm
yeah whatever oh it's lunch and I'll
come back to it and like that that
becomes until two o'clock yes wasted two
hours instead of being on your grind to
get it done right a lot of people say oh
I need to wake up two hours earlier to
get my stuff done but if you audit their
schedule mm-hmm chances are they're
wasting a ton of time during the day so
sometimes so the question is how do I
overcome my insecurities about my art so
sometimes I'm listening to my art and I
don't think it's good enough or I I hear
it and I I'm just like maybe I should
pull this maybe I should not I think
we've already gone over this a little
bit yeah so it took me 350 videos until
I wasn't embarrassed by my videos right
350 public videos on my youtube channel
until I wasn't embarrassed like I
couldn't watch it
and then 700 something till I inspired
myself where I watched it like man like
getting good negates pretty good but 700
something videos and so it's normal and
everybody goes through it I think I
think given what your mission is I think
it's great to even share that like I
think you should share that you're
feeling insecure about it mm-hmm you're
worried about this I'm nervous like it I
use another one I'm still nervous like
2020 song I'm still nervous yeah and
that gives permission but like that
you're still doing it you're nervous but
you're not crippled by it you're scared
but you're still posting pushing through
that yeah but but not trying to be tough
guy yeah I have everything figured out
and this is great and fronting that you
think it's fire mm-hmm but instead
saying I'm I don't know I don't know if
it's very good but I'm putting it out
yeah okay because you become a hero like
that is that is heroic if you think it's
great yeah and it's gonna win for sure
and you put it out there's nothing
heroic in that right it's in the I'm I'm
afraid and I'm doing it anyway then that
gives permission to other people to do
the same thing right and that's
inspirational illness that's intuitive
what's your mission yeah it's my mission
right you want to influence people yeah
and so if I think you've got all figured
out and you thought dreaming was fire
then what am i learning okay when I come
up with something fire I'm gonna share
it too but no you were afraid to post
its taking you X number of months to get
it up there yeah and finally press you
know send a record or like yeah post now
now gives me the inspiration to go and
say okay he was worried about that and
he still did it maybe I can do that too
not rapping but something else
yeah right like I've been sketching a
lot and I've always been afraid to post
it a Cosmo posted his so I'm just gonna
I'm gonna post mine too and yeah so I
think when you are feeling that then
like that those could be lyrics in your
song mm-hmm right when you're feeling it
then you you share
about it or when you're posting your
song Instagram you put in the captions
my insecurities yeah yeah huh okay and
then and then by letting it out it has
less control over you it does yeah it
doesn't it's not as strong on you
anymore
every time you tell your story and
you're worried about judgment oh my god
what do people think that I did drugs
every time you tell a story the judgment
burns a little less it's easier to tell
the story mm-hmm right and then it
inspires other people to say yeah I went
down that same path and like it's
possible to clean up and it's possible
to then still go and get your goals
right so when you're feeling nervous
it's great it means you're doing
something heroic yeah and you need to
share that and embrace it yeah and that
will be the shield to inspire other
people to go off and do it themselves
thank you coming in awesome thank you a
hug appreciate appreciate it if you want
to get coached by me one on one to help
you build your brain and make money as a
thought leader check out my next
workshop in Toronto the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there